okay welcome everybody welcome back this
is now one third of the big room we were
in just in this morning it's fantastic
isn't it so now we have 45 minutes about
health and the interest is enormous and
perhaps we can also dig little bit into
that why are we so obsessed with food
nutrition health what's good for you and
every week we learn something new isn't
it on the tabloid it's on the television
now in Sweden we have a new diet
eight-week 800 calorie diet that is
supposed to be good for you a few weeks
terrible it sounds awful last year I
think it was the five colon to diet some
of you tried it you can I have so you
can be honest yeah yeah yeahs your fries
a lot those two days don't you its all
full led to okay so let's bring science
into this topic let's ask one of the
best nutritionists in the world marion
Nestle here and also Nestle I didn't say
I didn't say that is so funny though and
Jessica was also giving a speech in the
morning and we have met crystianna
before so I think you're familiar with
the panel and I will warm them up for a
few minutes and then i will ask four
questions by you so please prepare some
good questions for this knowledgeable
panel okay so good afternoon everybody
and yeah so please Marianne can I start
with you if if I am asked you what is a
healthy diet 2016 what would you answer
well I'll give you a strict nutrition
and Syria time it's a diet that meets
all
Armaan's for essential nutrients and
calories in the right proportions for
health and longevity couldn't be easier
why is it so complicated well because
there are a lot of nutrients and because
there are a lot of different kinds of
foods and world cuisines differ
enormously and it is quite possible to
eat a healthy diet that will maximize
health and longevity with foods that are
totally different from one another
ranging from the inner wit in the Arctic
who we mostly fat from Wales I was just
there I saw it you know two people who
eat nothing but vegetables to everything
in between and as long as you're getting
all of the required nutrients and enough
calories not too many you'll define your
define enjoy what you eat but you know
what when it comes to vegetables for
instance and fruits and what wins Sweden
called dance floor bread that is rye
bread quite dark bread not so not so
sweet when it's supposed to be good for
worried those things we've learned that
this is better than eating proteins from
from the animal world and has has the
scientific evidence of this is there any
scientific sort of base for this well if
you're talking about protein no proteins
is open konstandin nutrients they are
the same yeah I mean there's a big
difference between talking about
nutrients and foods people don't eat
nutrients unless you're taking pills I
don't advise it people eat food and
fruits have many many different kinds of
nutrients in different proportions and
the you know the classic key to
healthful diet says you eat a variety of
foods and because their nutrient
composition complements one another so
if you eat some of this and some of this
and some of this and not too much of
anything you don't ever have to think
about nutrients because they take care
of themselves okay so let's make it a
little bit more complicated just again
yeah you you into Nepal just a few weeks
ago didn't you to give him yeah speech
yeah when I happen to listen that gonna
listen to it when I was running the
other day so it was it was a good
company it must have been a stimulating
get around it was actually because you
lift the very important question of of
what is healthy what is healthy for us
in this room what has healthy for four
people that you meet a lot that's low
income post-conflict countries and so on
would you like to tell us a little bit
more about your view
yes I mean I mean Marian's exactly right
we there's a way to eat a diet a dietary
pattern that fulfills our nutrient needs
and and promotes health but I think we
have to realize we are not alone on the
planet we have to have multiple goals
about the way we eat the planet being
the one issue when we think about
healthy diets we want to also be
thinking about planetary health now when
you start to think about how important
food is in our culture how food is so
globalized we start thinking about
health of societies and that means
equitable access to foods so to me when
I think about diet I don't only think
about human health or promoting the and
ensuring that we meet our nutrient
requirements but we're thinking about
planetary health we're thinking about
economic health we're thinking about
socio-cultural health so I think about
it as a multi-dimensional issue I know
Marian does as well thank you gave that
she gave you the answer that that you
asked for but I think we need to start
thinking about the way we eat and how it
affects multiple issues of our society
not just our own health but but so how
different these roses and what we eat
also becomes important yeah and and for
some of we can put costs on human health
we can put costs on some issues around
climate change but there's a lot of
other things we don't have true kaustubh
we don't know the cost of biodiversity
loss for example which then allows for
us to eat a variety of foods it's very
hard to cost some of these things so it
makes it less important if we can't put
an economic piece or a price tag to it
particularly for politicians they don't
see an economic cost to these things
it's very hard to them
push them to to change so we know some
of the costs of human health but even
that it's a guessing game on the obesity
we have certain price tags of what it
could potentially cost the healthcare
system but there's a lot of other price
tags to the way we eat that we don't
understand and a lot of trade-offs to
even healthy diets we know that the
Mediterranean diet while healthy that
Mediterranean diet can't be olive oil
the major staple of the Mediterranean
diet that can't really be grown in
California we know there's a huge water
footprint issue can be grown in certain
puya Italy where I'm from but it can't
be grown in California we have water
constraints there so we need to start
thinking about what's a healthy diet
which the Mediterranean is but there
could be potential trade offs to the
planet for the animal was there when
Joanne rocks drum talk this morning and
that is it is also possible from a
scientific point of view to find a way
of doing this I thought it was a bit
optimistic the way he put it but but in
that case we need to find the synergies
we need to find the sort of food on our
plate that is both good for us and the
rest of the planet and and also along
cited a sustainable solution for it so
it becomes immediately very much
complicated than just going to the shop
Christian I I know that you are very
interested in cooking and and and
inviting your friends we heard that in
the morning and why do you think it has
become sort of so attached with emotions
this this thing with with inviting
people over but why is it so sensitive
in a way that what made you think it's
know that this is I think it's probably
rather decaying and I might encourage my
colleagues and friends to do more
invitations because i think in germany
at least a culturally it has been much
more frequent that you invite people and
also the family meals that they were
together
lunch and evening meals the family SAP
together and now I think me in many
cases people just just grab a sandwich
and eat it in a corner and don't talk
anymore but isn't it the case that when
we invite the the ambition level is well
I mean when you eat together or you
prepare mere you take more care and it's
for more people and I notices when
myself and I cook for myself it's very
very simple it's just the potatoes I
think you know but was it a priority
holidays huh a bit of vegetables and not
I mean no no more dishes no when
you bend when I invite people it's a
soup and it's a salad and it's a it's a
main cause and it's it's a nice dessert
and some cheese or something like that
meaning that and it's already a comp a
mixture of different things and if the
more diverse it is or the more mixture
it is the more healthy it will be I
think at the end in tendency if you just
don't focus you don't eat rice all the
time but you eat different things can we
ask the nutritionist is diversity per se
a good for us absolutely so I've heard
even that you can tell by the colors of
the food on absolutely them because
foods have different nutrient
compositions and so I mean dr. the
Japanese dietary guidelines specify
usually 30 different fruits a day in
very small amounts that is the trick
excellent advice excellent alight so
please and do we have their microphones
now for you guys there is one over there
and one there so please Oh raise your
hands and we can have some questions
going and why you are thinking that yes
it has to add something I think we
really do want to try to achieve dietary
diversity and there was a lot of
discussion when the formulation of the
sustainable development goals were
having to include it as a target but it
didn't make it in and that's the biggest
issue in a lot of the inner cities of
the United States but it's also big
issue in low and middle income countries
people don't get the dietary diversity
that they need the dietary quality the
food safety but was someone erased in
the morning also the quality of food
and if they're spending seventy or
eighty percent of your income on food
like you are in Bangladesh or rural
Rwanda and you have food price increases
of specific commodities or those fruits
and vegetables we know that there's
direct links between social unrest and
conflict and food prices and this is
really alarming as we move forward of
how to address the diversity issue this
I think there should be a ban on potato
chips just bantha and I think it's right
I am potatoes or something really i love
potatoes and potato chips are probably
not the worst but they are fried in a
lot of loyal which is also not good for
you and people eat much too much of them
and this is the indians are not healthy
it's just not healthy and and I think
also I mean human nature has developed
some requirements for particular things
so I think meat as part of it I mean we
are meat eaters by biology but now we
are in another ancient absolutely and we
end about but and the problem is also
that when you really do heavy work you
need a lot of energy and then you eat
fat and meat and in Germany for example
their habits changed very much because
at the time people really were working
bodily hard then you do unique you need
this kind of nourishment but we'll come
out here the band so the texts and all
that well I'm say I want to suggest you
yeah I have a question there so can I
please have a microphone to the later
there while you are please Miriam a
while the micro gesture yes oh I just
wanted to say that we must have evolved
to eat animal products because animal
products have one vitamin that is that
you cannot obtain from plants and so
it's necessary to have some kind of
animal products if you're going to have
balance nutrient intake but that could
be from fish of course it could be
something as long as we have a fairy
brother but let's or dairy products or
eggs but the some animal product I think
the red meat don't let us get started on
a fish when it comes to that should we
so much cereals this is no this is in
evolution of humans is this is a very
late economy relate okay came very late
and it's not about some not advice here
don't we I mean it's M&S but they don't
want to ban the serious dude no but it's
less healthy than people think
everything in moderation everything is
moderation please yes yes thank you am I
wanted to ask like we as consumers not
really involved in the production system
and the food system how can we be more
responsible about having a more
variation in our diet and our health and
being not as a tree yard but about the
the food since them want us to decide or
to eat yeah that's a good one I think
it's most for you Miriam how can we
change I'll vote with your fork um you
know how do you when you do it yourself
you have money you have choices that
people without money don't have and
every time you make a choice of the food
you are making an economic decision
about what you're going to be buying and
if you don't think that the food
products that are heavily marketed
should be purchased don't purchase them
and make sure that the institutions
around you don't either makes a big
difference I know that you have a good
tip when you enter a supermarket you
don't walk into the let's center of it
actually supermarkets have caught on to
that that they would you have to tell
them oh that well it used to be just a
few years ago that if you walked around
the periphery of the supermarket it's
where all the real foods were because
that's where the refrigerated cases are
and it was easier for them to stock it
so you would get the produce in the meat
and the fish and the dairy products
around you just never set foot in the
center aisles but the supermarkets have
figured that one out
so the processed food are also liked the
food is sprinkled in all around now
making it harder but Jessica would you
also like to comment on this question
about the consumer I think it's also
just just being more aware of what
you're buying where it's sore store it's
coming from and that can be hard without
really constructive informative labels
but i think it's learning more about
sourcing of foods and it's exactly what
Marion said you have the right to and
you have the ability to choose from a
variety of foods and making informed
choices and you know even though we vote
certain ways it doesn't always work out
that way but you know I think it is
important demand-supply will answer to
demand so consumers have more power than
they think they do it oh it's always
worked that way so if you created a big
demand for healthy foods industry will
answer to that and I think it's it's
it's something that we need to think
about so and and we've seen these shifts
in diet patterns we've seen these
changes happen where demand has really
shifted the supply so I you know we
often talk about this dream completely
or controls everything but i think they
also answer to what consumers want to so
I think there's both right there's the
controlling the food environment but
there's also a demand is that there's a
there's a relationship happening it's
not so one or the other no because if
there were more demand I mean this is
apparently a market that doesn't really
function the way it could because we
have a lot of strong players there it
certainly doesn't work in low-income
settings it's much more difficult please
we have a question of it there whoever
has the microphone and whoever has the
microphone night whoever has the
microphone has the question yeah it's on
the way so we can add a few questions
yes he has it I said it's right here I
want to make one question about I made
research on nutritional status of ever
married women in Bangladesh she
mentioned about Bangladesh
and how can we improve the new
undernutrition for the ultra poor women
in Bangladesh and especially for the
Islam areas women and another question
is that for the night workers what kind
of food cessation may improve their
digest capability or guess true
improvement from a specific West
nutrient here to the nutritionist ok but
the Bangladesh question goes very nicely
with what Muhammad Yunus said in the
morning doesn't it yeah with first of
all it's an income problem and you need
a certain income to be able to choose
those foods
tikka with women there needs to be much
more of a focus on empowerment we know
that in rural areas all over the world
women are leading in agriculture so how
do we ensure that they don't have a huge
work and time burden but at the same
time have support services I think the
focus in the under nutrition community
has been on these thousand days what we
call from conception to two years of age
to try to reduce stunting which is what
angus deeton had talked about but more
and more realizing that if we focus
earlier in the lifecycle adolescent
girls keep them in school delay early
marriages delay early pregnancies you
could not only improve the nutritional
status of the children that they do have
eventually but you improve their health
status so there's much more of a focus
now on women's health and nutrition not
just maternal health and child nutrition
so there's we're shifting now into
thinking well women are actually
important in the world oh we need to
start empowering them and sure that it's
a coincidence that we happen to be they
have the health and they have the
services they need the ish the issue in
international development is that
there's been a bit of too much put on
women too many programs and
interventions and we know that
empowering women also involves men
they're part of the equation may I add
something here that I find quite quite
paradoxical when my mother was was young
in the 1960s processed food was
something very modern in Sweden and very
smart and she was one of those clever
women that wanted to make a career and
she did thanks to the processed food she
opened a tin and she had plenty of time
to do other stuff that she thought was
more interesting for her so this is also
something which sometimes tend to forget
when we talk about processed food making
it a little bit more complicated we have
many I many hands in the
a in the air please hello there hi there
are so many brains on the stage now and
I would like to ask all of you a
question and I would like you to
categorize or summarize what are the
three top categories important for
health for personal and for World Health
okay and I would like each one of you to
answer in 3b thwarts thank you you're
doing my job there well thank you very
much who wants to start there's ago the
three things that I think will impact
human health yep decreasing inequities
decreasing conflict and social unrest is
that two or one could go for two and
again a access to affordable healthy
foods if I were to make those choices of
the things that I find important in my
work but in equities is huge right Mario
would you like that takes care of it I
mean you aren't you something about
income inequity that's the the highest
priority it has to be and that requires
enormous social change which is why
nobody wants to talk about it you know
if you want to make a personal choice
then you eat more plant foods and less
animal foods but that's way down on the
list of priorities if you're going to do
it on a global basis it's just easier
and there's nothing wrong with doing
easy things I mean that's why in the
United States the focus on trying to get
people to consume fewer sugar-sweetened
beverages is so important because it's
an easy target and there's been enormous
progress and it's a success and I think
people who are in the food movement
needs success because the underlying
problems are so difficult to address
because they require changing society
could I very hard can I do a follow-up
on on yours asking the panelists to give
an example of something we can buy
tomorrow or today to invite our friends
that is both fine for my health and the
planet can I can I just have a
sipi under plan and implanted yes food
that is good for health and the play
wholesome planet is it possible to make
that choice Jessica sustainable palm oil
let us stay up online okay so I believe
that don't like that putting that like
in quotes sustainable palm oil is there
such a thing there is a roundtable to
try to regulate the current palm oil
crisis that we're seeing but again the
palm oil story is complicated we hear a
lot of bad things about it on the
environment side with deforestation loss
and and loss of biodiversity but and we
know it's not a great foil for health
all that's why I was supposed Malaysian
government would say that's wrong so but
it also uses less land because Percy
what it produces a lot of oil right it
uses less land it uses less fertilizer
compared to other oil seeds so there's
always trade-offs to everything and
trying to understand those but we know
that now a lot of you have heard about
the orangutan in sumatra that's all
because of the slash-and-burn
agriculture palm oil there is a way to
put more regulation on such a ubiquitous
oil that's used in fifty percent of all
world products not just food so to me
that we're doing a big impact yeah to
really regulate the sustainability of
palm oil that's my commodity that's
another panel please another question
yes the or where is the microphone sorry
there it is so please and also I would
like to ask depend on what the European
is the best way to educate people about
how to basically cook healthy food it
seems to me like four centuries this was
carried on by generation to generation
and now we're seeing more and more
people who do not know how to cook
presumably good food and since the
parents cannot teach the kids what would
be how do it we address this challenge
well that leaves it up to schools
doesn't it what there's no other option
so I learned how to cook in school I'm
old enough so that we still had the
whole
economics classes when I went to school
and everybody learned to cook no was
quite useful christiana well the eating
habits are very very different so we
cannot I mean you'd say palm oil I don't
know it sort of no concern in our
countries I mean it's totally irrelevant
so it really depends on whether we are
rich or whether we're poor and in which
part of the world we are living and blip
eating habits in different cultures are
so different and some are not good some
I'm not healthy say yeah people are used
to eating stuff which is not good for
them because this is from the upbringing
and I think there are some some things
that your chick and education system do
well I mean schools of course but maybe
it's already too late I think the mums I
mean the mothers who do most of the day
there must be programs for women who to
learn how to but also fathers you know
fathers if ya after they usually don't
well some inside even is under it ok
again depends on the culture yeah what
yeah it's our turn there to give the
children parents must learn but it's
good for the children and and i think
that the eating habits of probably
settled babe it's the age of 23 or
something like okay very early very
early on very early on jessica could the
could the sustainable development goals
be used in the education system with
special focus on food since it's a way
in your own rock stone was mentioning it
this morning that a way of sort of
taking taking something that is really
close to people and go from there to see
what is this doing for for me from a
family for my society for the planet
yeah absolutely i mean the whole
discipline of sustainable developments
really starting to come online johan
rock strim teaches an online course on
the planetary boundaries which is part
of sustainable development as cg2 is all
about agriculture food and nutrition
with targets of childhood obesity
flattening reducing stunting and wasting
so there's there's key targets in the
sustainable development goals that you
could use as education to how would you
meet those goals and we now have 14
years to achieve those goals but how do
we do that and there's a lot of
different what you could teach a whole
class on just sdg to 100 nutrition and
how how you would get that from
different perspectives different
cultures because the sustainable
development goals are for everyone it's
not just poor countries like the MDGs
were course yeah every country's two
committees yeah good thank you who has
the microphone there thank you yes ok
apparently I need to stand up please do
i was wondering because it feels as
though you're putting quite a lot of the
responsibility on individuals about
parents teaching their children and also
about the individuals keeping informed
at the same time we have a lot of
information not just about food that's
being bombarded at us every day we only
have 24 hours a day all of us that's
sort of the only currency we have in
common and I guess what I'm wondering
it's more what can we do to ease this
for the individuals how can we make it
not only easier to choose by
communicating the right information but
who should be doing it and in what way
how much responsibility can we actually
put on the individuals thank you who
wants to start that one that's why I
suggested schools that's an
institutional approach the education has
been demonstrably useless in teaching
individuals about what to eat it doesn't
work because you make food choices in an
environment in which you're bombarded by
conflicting information and a huge
amount of marketing much of the
marketing is aimed at confusing the
science and leaving people confused so
you know you want governments to do
policies that are going to make the
Healthy Choice the easy choice and the
preferred
choice even better one step more so to
the extent that policies make healthier
foods cheaper so that there's a built-in
incentive to buy them and there's no
reason why governments couldn't do that
if they wanted to the real issue here is
political will where is the political
will for a lot of this if there were
political will I think it would be a lot
easier and there wouldn't be these
enormous fights and controversies about
it but that doesn't be more of top-down
than bottom up here it has to be both
top-down doesn't work without bottom up
and when it comes to the individuals i
can i can feel that there's a lot of lot
of guilt also when it comes to food I
mean it's really you can I can I really
eat this or do I become fat or can I
really buy this or do i affect somebody
else on the other in another country and
and and and I think the more complicated
this issue becomes the more there is a
risk that we actually don't really take
it in yes I'm going to go back to the
simplicity Michael but how is that
Michael Pollan said it in seven words
eat plants not too much mostly you know
mostly food and not totally food or eat
food mostly plants not too much it's
really that's all there is to it but I
wouldn't agree to what you said it
should make healthy food cheaper I think
we do not pay enough we do not pay oh
the value of what we eat you know that
Spencer a little and that some is so
cheap and you cannot really possibly
understand how long chain it could be
create food which is so cheap as we buy
at the supermarket I feel guilty about
that I think it's incredible something
is wrong it's not anything is wrong
there there is some too much subsidies
or I don't know what but it's not it's
not really logical or how it was work at
least in Western countries I mean how
much of our income do we spend on food
not much when I was a child was much
more
I mean I remember that our families
served money on saved money on food so
we ate very usually brother very much
concerned with the prices of the food
which is not no longer the case it's so
cheap compared to income as this is
really bad about it and I think we could
um also in agriculture so we could have
a lot of improvements if you would be
prepared to pay a little bit more for
the food and have regulations which
which allow as we can trust the
producers the producers are under big
pressure to make it cheaper and in and
its really a whole I think just
disgusting that you learn that farmers
cannot live on the prices they get for
their milk for example in Germany and
this is immoral incredible and then of
course they do things which they've
tried to save money on I don't know what
may be so welcomed there are we done and
we are not prepared to pay that price it
costs to prepare this type of food and
again I think it's in Western cultures
you talk much too much about healthiness
of the food the food never has been as
healthy as it is now food never has been
as good entries now and it's not just
the bio products also the other food we
get we can buy it supermarkets I mean if
it's not potato chips but still but
until the global hood in general is
really really high standard and also the
health of the people is I standard in
here here here here it's very different
mal nutritionist is increasing although
the children mortality is decreasing so
so it's not sold yet increasing health
is increasing please another question
here reducing
in that case I have to repeat the
question because there is a television
camera somewhere so we have a problem
who has the microphone you'll get it in
a mo there is this so fine good thank
you for waiting yeah right so I
understand what you're saying and I
agree with everything and however
there's there's something missing from
here we're making intellectual arguments
for this now intellectually I understand
what is nutritional I understand what
I'm supposed to eat I'm teaching my
children to make the healthy choice but
what's missing for me in this discussion
is where is the emotional connection to
what we buy to our purchases to how we
just because I understand intellectually
doesn't mean I never eat junk I do right
because I know that it's an emotional
connection and all across the world
right we're sharing these emotional
connections to food that have nothing to
do with how educated we are in healthy
choices so where is the research and
what's happening how do we educate
people and to overcome ah that's just an
emotional connection don't buy those
sweets right what's happening because
that's what a missing getting is part of
our biology this is back there the
emotional connection comes from its
Avenue if you are not agree this is
really a very unpleasant feeling so you
want to eat and and then I mean if food
is for everyone for the but you could
also change the word system of the
barrel don't you the problem is that the
food industry of course plays on what is
a track what seems to be attractive
sugar is something which is biologically
very attractive for children because
they're it's a very quick source of
energy so you cannot teach people not to
like sugar because this is our nature
and and therefore you and this is where
the industry of course built on and and
this is a bit of the problem and maybe
one should I relations day I don't know
one way of approaching this question
isn't that what we now call nudging
trying to
to decrease the size of the plate
serving the salads before the meat and
so on so we we actually see the good
stuff before and that happens to to work
quite well yessica you you have
experienced this having mean I think
again it we have these individual
factors and these these nudges that we
can change behavior a little bit but I
agree with you on the tradition side
Halloween in the United States we give
out candy to kids it's basically like
giving crack cocaine the kids and they
come to the door and that you know if
someone tries to change it and said
there well i'm gonna give nuts to kids
people just stare you like come on come
on it's once a year but it's not once a
year we've a lot of our traditions
center around food birthdays cakes when
you go into people's offices they have
candy sitting out there's lots of
cultural issues around food and when
it's acceptable so I think it's not
deserving change no actually but I think
I agree that there's the nudges and
there's the individual changes of the
consumer engaging with a food
environment where there then they have
preferences they have choices sometimes
very few sometimes a lot but then we do
have these macro things that need to
change of what marion was talking about
we need to think about government
policies we need to think about the role
of industry how do we hold them
accountable to ensuring that the food
system is healthier trade big issues on
trade right now that's going to really
dictate the kind of foods it's moving
around the world so we have these macro
issues that we need to deal with along
with these more individual type issues
and as Marion said it's kind of the top
and bottom we need all of it and that's
what makes working in food systems
research so complicated but I think we
need to start addressing the complex and
being okay with having lots of solutions
and not just one solution there needs to
be a lot of things that we're doing
and people are never comfortable with
that it's easier to focus on attacks or
a bio fortified crop or of course you
know it's easier to do kind of these
silver bullet approaches but we know
after 4050 years of working in food and
nutrition and international development
that's not working we need to embrace
the complexity of the food system macro
and micro emotional part that you can
say something very shortly about the
emotional part this very reason of
course we have an emotional attachment
to food we're putting it in our bodies
it's part of us and food is delicious
it's one of life's greatest pleasures
and it breaks my heart when people are
anxious and afraid of it and are afraid
that if they eat a potato chip they're
going to die on the spot I love potato
chips I'm gonna put it on record I love
chips I am NOT on keep many I don't
thank you folks of course I don't eat
many but I'm when I want them I want
them and fortunately I can have them as
I suspected this panel has not given
given any easy or answers or even
addressed it the way we hoped for
because we all hope forcing a single
silver bullet a simple solution
something we can write on a piece paper
and go to the shop and or talk to our
politicians as on what we've learned is
that the food system the food politics
the health problems on earth and the the
problem regarding the the planet itself
is so interconnected and complicated so
we need a broad approach to this problem
but as as we are understanding that I
think we have taken the first step
haven't we yeah so in in five years when
you come back to stop on please when you
come back in five years and ten
years oh now here comes the Nobel
laureate again what will be the
difference do you think do you think we
will be by certain that case what will
have risen and this is the biggest
problem I think you have to play
something about the population increase
yeah and we cannot I mean the planet is
full yeah and the country is taken and
this is I would like to I think it's
really important also to think about
agricultural development because the
land is limited we cannot break we
cannot increase the deformable country
inside so we have to learn how to I mean
we have some people this morning except
we shouldn't always set on yield but on
quality I mean we cannot afford it
actually we need that the high yields in
order to be able to and you know what
I'm optimistic so I think with all this
knowledge we've got now and with us it
goes from the UN we can out you don't
get many of those issues at the same
time you are not one by one so we may be
a bit wiser in five years time than we
are now I I think so yeah I thought so
too I would like to stop there okay
thank you very much panel and thank you
very much but the audience
[Applause]